i um am contemplating
some possible litigation
around this clip that we're about to see
we have reached 100 000 subscribers on
youtube the david pakman show surpassed
the 200 000 subscriber mark on youtube
400 000 subscribers on
youtube 500 000
subscribers 600 000
subscribers 700 000
subscribers on youtube yesterday as many
of you know but as many of you don't
know
this program is on youtube convalescent
plasma
thank you to our youtube subscribers who
now number
more than 750
800 000 subscribers that's an eight
followed by five zeros that's an eight
followed by five zeros the david pakman
show youtube channel
has achieved and surpassed 900
000 subscribers in fact i think we now
are probably closer to 901
i went back and looked at the statistics
for our first month on youtube
in september of 2009 we had 711 views
total and we had 721 views
777 views 721 views
and four four subscribers dude we had
four subscribers we had i don't mean
that or subscribers subscribers maybe it
was our penny
to remember we had four subscribers
and four subscribers three of which were
probably
uh accounts my mom made okay hit some
really
interesting numbers in our
first month on youtube we had 30
subscribers
those are the right numbers subscribers
this actually isn't crazy it is uh
quite an accomplishment for us i mean
our youtube channel started
so small back in 2009 thanks to your
support and i'm talking about the trolls
as well i'm thanking the trolls as well
it was alleged that i
established sort of a race against sam
cedar to a million subscribers
i smell bots i smell bots so
look here here it is right now put this
video up look
folks ronald reagan has just informed me
that uh david pakman
has taken a lead in our race to get to a
million
subscribers and i
am making a personal appeal to you right
now
hit the subscribe button it's not
necessarily where i'm pointing to i
don't know where it is maybe it's
maybe it's down here or over there but
hit the subscribe button
don't let david pakman steal our valor
if we can automate a lot of these tasks
that some would consider maybe mindless
some would consider
low brain activity tasks somehow
bots that i have presumably used or paid
for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers this is a little bit of a
problem
pounding that subscribe button turning
that subscribe
the button you know all of the battle of
such all this stuff
we are using bots the the growth curve
has been accelerated
my thought is i don't know that we
should be drastically changing what
we're doing in order to get to our
subscribers that's an amazing goal based
on the recent subscriber trends
you could have a million subscribers and
no views and that's where our focus
continues to be
it's not like voting where you can only
vote once you can vote for everybody
okay i don't i i just don't even
understand what's happening right now
so uh this just as a heads up this is
all fake
it's all a joke the only serious part is
let's get to a million and finally i
asked the leaders of the region
political and religious israeli and
palestinian jewish and christian and
muslim to join us
god bless you god bless israel and god
bless the palestinians and god bless
the united states united
states
thank you very much it's disgusting guys
trust nothing other than your ability
to vote and to convince others to vote
that's it my friends thank you for your
trust
your support and the love i thank them
and i also thank you
thank you for everything you do and
congratulations
okay now this is sort of funny but some
people are furious